the FBI is warning about a popular
antivirus software linked to the
government of Russia
Kaspersky Lab products are widely used
by businesses and some government
offices across this country federal
officials are concerned the software may
be feeding user information to Russian
intelligence Geoff buguese is in
Washington where the White House head of
cybersecurity says the government needs
more help to fight these hackers Jeff
good morning good morning the White
House cyber czar said the threat to u.s.
systems and infrastructure extends
beyond Chinese and Russian hackers and
that quote small little countries you
wouldn't expect are also hitting us Rob
Joyce the man in charge of protecting
the u.s. from cyber threats offered a
sobering assessment of the country's
deficit in cyber defense to a group of
students right now we're about 300,000
people short and we've got roughly 3/4
of a million people doing cybersecurity
and if the industry could hire everybody
they wanted they would they would hire
another quarter million to almost a
third of a million more people Joyce
also expressed concern about the popular
antivirus software from Kaspersky Lab US
officials believe the company has ties
to Russian intelligence FBI officials
have met with private industry
representatives to relay concerns about
using this software already the federal
government is vowed not to use its
products but local and state governments
make extensive use of that software
Kaspersky Lab denies the accusations
calling them quote false allegations
Noora really interesting Jeff thank you
so much